Here are the correct answers. Fantastic work if you got at least one of those
correct. If either of these problems are giving you trouble, then watch the
solution and we'll figure it out together. To add these two fractions together,
we simply add the numerators. 3 n and 2 n equal 5 n. We leave the denominator
alone, so we have 5 n divided by 11. This problem is exactly like the one we saw
before. It's just we needed to combine the like terms and our numerator first.
For the second problem, we want to add the numerators a and b together, and keep
the denominator the same. Since we have a plus b divided by a plus b, we know
those reduce to 1. And finally, for this third one, we want to subtract a y from
this numerator. So we'll have 2 y minus 1 minus 1 y, we subtract the like terms
to get y minus 1 for our numerator. Now we want to factor our denominator to see
if it can reduce with our numerator since our numerator has changed and it turns
out that's a great move because we can factor and reduce and equivalence of 1. Y
minus 1 divided by y minus 1 equals 1. This leaves us with the answer of 1
divided by y plus 2. If you got the first two, excellent work, and I know this
one might of given you some trouble.